we have these three big theories of 20th
century physics statistical mechanics
general relativity and quantum mechanics
it's always seemed that well the second
law is almost something you just prove
from pure thought general relativity is
something you kind of have to wheel in
from the outside and say well the
universe happens to work this way
quantum mechanics the same thing all
three of those theories seem to be
derivable and it's remarkable that laws
of physics could be derivable and that's
been a thing that made this story of the
second law much more poignant for me
because what happens is the
characterization of the Observer
necessary to derive the second law
General activity and quantum mechanics
it's the same characterization that sort
of gives more strength to saying well
I'm going to pick an observer that works
like this that's a bigger pivot point
for that